quand on s'adresse à un public hostile
il faut quand même garder à l'esprit
qu'ils aient un procès qui risque de
vous être fait et qui peut être injuste
chuck norris tient et où green a réagi
lundi à ces jeunes à rennes et
strasbourg mais irrite les juifs tout le
temps nash neige
je sais aussi qu'il m'est arrivé de
blessés certains d'entre vous par mes
propos
je veux ce soir être très clair avec le
point commun c'est l'émotion dans les
trois cas on a un appel donc plutôt à
tous qu logos dans le cadre d'obama on à
l'appel à l'espoir parce qu'encore une
fois l'espoir c'est vraiment un auteur
qui est très important et qui vient
répondre au pessimisme du moins que
certains pouvaient vous pouvez lui
opposer après après une défaite est
presque un storytelling le rêve
américain existe encore puisque je
l'incarnent
bien solitaire
on a un discours d'adhésion par l'espoir
avec le slogan yes we can qui repose sur
un constat qui au final est assez simple
c'est que l'espoir c'est un gros moteur
de conviction c'est une émotion qui est
très très forte on est clairement dans
le pathos mais une émotion qui incite
aussi à l'action et à la poursuite de ce
qu'on recherche
[Musique]
donc l'idée c'est oui nous pouvons mais
si nous voulons et surtout si nous
faisons il a pu m'arriver de vous donner
le sentiment que ce n'était pas mon
souci que j'avais d'autres priorités
c'est assez rare effectivement de voir
un président faire faire son mea culpa
il faut voir que donc les contextes sont
radicalement différents avec obama parce
que dans un cas donc on a un discours de
remobilisation et dans l'autre cas on
espère presse que la démobilisation d'un
mouvement qui était celui des gilet
jaune donc si les deux espèrent
l'adhésion à un projet qui est le leurre
puisque macron ensuite en vient à étaler
étaler son projet la façon de faire est
évidemment très très différente puisque
le seul dénominateur commun qu'on a
finalement c'est toujours l'émotion ici
on est aussi vraiment dans l'émotionnel
à fond dans le pathos à fond et pour
faire baisser la température du coût du
mouvement et bah on s'excuse là où obama
quelque part
transformait sa défaite en victoire
emmanuel macron lui au contraire va
faire pénitence il à faire presque dans
la contrition en admettant des erreurs
et une part de responsabilité je sais
aussi qu'il m'est arrivé de blessés
certains d'entre vous par mes propos
je veux ce soir être très clair à vous
si je me suis battu pour bousculer le
système politique en place les habitudes
les hypocrisies c'est précisément parce
que je crois plus que tout dans notre
pays que je laime les retraités
constituent une partie précieuse de
notre nation pour ceux qui touchent
moins de 2000 euros par mois nous
annulerons en 2019 la hausse de csg subi
cette année
l'effort qui leur a été demandé était
trop important il n'était pas juste
revenir en arrière nous affaiblir et
alors même que nous sommes en train de
recréer des emplois dans tous les
secteurs
cependant
le gouvernement et le parlement devons
aller plus loin pour mettre fin aux
avantages indus et aux évasions fiscales
le dirigeant d'une entreprise française
doit payer ses impôts en france et les
grandes entreprises qui font du profit
doivent-ils payer d'impôts c'est la
simple justice dans le cadre des manuels
macro on a encore une fois un appel à
l'émotion mais alors cette fois une
émotion qui est différente qui est
l'excusé la recherche d' empathie ne
sert presque l'idée d'un caractère
anecdotique voyez c'est accidentel du
propos il ya cette idée j'ai pas fait
exprès moi je suis pas comme ça c'était
un c'était un accident et derrière pour
renforcer cette clémence on essaye de
prendre une idée qui est populaire au
sein au sein du mouvement d'aidé gilet
jaune et et pour les français de manière
générale qui est un patron d'entreprises
françaises doit payer ses impôts en
france donc en fait on essaye d'obtenir
une adhésion en deux temps qui passe par
l'excusent et ensuite par la reprise
d'une idée populaire il faut voir quand
même qui cible en donner il parle des
retraités y cible quand même d'aider pas
des pans de la population qui ont pu
être heurté par c'est par ces propos
donc on égrène dans un contexte c'est à
dire que on le voit bien aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron il va pas à la télé tous
les jours pour s'excuser à chaque fois
que les gens ne sont pas contents donc
il ya un contexte on pense quand même
que c'est une contrition qui s'inscrit
dans un contexte on s'inscrit dans un
mouvement clairement à dlj par l'osq
signal téléphonique au vice-président
les fédérales
résultat tu touches la
grèce de russie nicolas présidente iab
recherche consiste king rage de nos cac
cash dernier no cry bongo à date je te
tape om est prêt initio à sabatini
maraudeur ryan
cochrane alb
on peut projeter armstrong sky au bout
du chis street and in the shell gas gas
gas oil quand je dis petit levi ou green
à vache novès tient et où green a réagi
denis est un jeune arabe estrade igor
mais il fait litière tout le temps
alors oui si on en fait un phénomène qui
est la recherche de l'adhésion par
l'identification ici donc volodymyr
zelensky commence son discours en
signalant qu'il va parler en russe et
parce qu'il s'adresse précisément au
peuple euris et l'idée sous jacente qui
lie à derrière c'est certes nous sommes
différentes ailleurs il le dit dans son
discours mais nous avons plus en commun
que ce que vous pensez nous ne sommes
pas vos ennemis nous sommes des humains
comme vous regardez d'ailleurs je parle
votre langue et il y reviendra ensuite
d'ailleurs en disant vous êtes nombreux
à avoir des proches en ukraine vous êtes
déjà venu visiter notre pays vous nous
connaissez vous connaissez nos principes
donc il ya vraiment une volonté de de
créer une adhésion par l'identification
qui est un procédé d'ailleurs qu'on
retrouvera par la suite dans quasiment
tous ses discours au parlement il
essaiera toujours de coller au plus près
des exemples qui parle en fonction des
pays auxquels auxquels ils s'adressent
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup
plus de mal finalement à combattre ou à
être indifférent à ce qui nous semble
proche plutôt qu'est ce qui nous semble
complètement étranger on en guerre il
sera ce beau moral évoquera on n'en a
cure il sera s'il est admis un avocat et
un toit aux chaussures grèce qui rebours
on a encore une fois un discours qui est
éminemment émotionnel avec la recherche
de l'identification mais aussi avec des
images si vous voulez qu'ils sont qui
sont très très fortes on essaye encore
une fois de faire appel aux au pathos
parce que dans des cadres comme ça c'est
vrai que le logo c'est toujours d'abord
rappelé mais ce qui va véritablement
susciter l'adhésion derrière c'est
l'émotion c'est le pathos le seul
problème qui peut se poser c'est que
parfois
on va dire les querelles de personnes
dépasse les querelles d'idées donc quand
on s'adresse à un public hostile il faut
quand même garder à l'esprit qu'ils
aient un procès qui risque de vous être
fait et qui peut être injuste qui est le
procès en sincérité donc il faut
véritablement bien choisir ses exemple
essayer de ne pas en faire trop parce
que sinon vous avez un processeur
sincérité qui va être fait de
véritablement géré le juste milieu pour
aller dans l'émotion dans l'émotion qui
qui fait mouche qui touche et aussi un
peu de logos derrière pour appuyer cette
émotion et et pas forcément faire celui
qui a voulu faire pleurer dans les
chaumières
[Musique]